internet legend airsoft fatty recently
got permabanned by twitch
for not moderating his chat and for
allegedly allowing hate speech to run
wild the fact that this isn't bigger
news
is indicative of a growing trend on the
platform
the days of twitch using permanent bands
as a last resort
are gone and so could be the wild west
version of twitch that once used them so
sparingly
guys hit that subscribe button already
and while you're at it hit the
notification bell so
you never miss me yelling about twitch
in another video
ever again so this guy airsoft fatty who
got famous for having lightsaber fights
in his driveway
recently got permabanned by twitch for
not moderating his chat
the email screenshot he posted to
twitter said it could have been for a
few reasons
quote allowing text-to-speech donations
on stream that contain hateful symbols
allowing users in your chat to
repeatedly spam hateful slurs
without taking any moderation actions to
remove the messages
allowing viewers submitted videos
focused on xenophobic ideology to play
on stream
end quote now i reached out to
airsoftfatty whose real name is chris
and while he wasn't up for an interview
his manager wrote back
with this statement quote someone said
the n-word via voice chat in a game he
was playing
he never removed the vod or informed
anyone that could help him of this
instance and was banned he was smoking
and he didn't think about that being a
possible ban
it was a mistake end quote from there
the statement says that they're in the
process of appealing the decision
and hiring moderators for the channel
quote it was an honest mistake for
everyone involved and we are looking
into making sure we have more moderators
and that those moderators
have the ability to communicate with
management better to ensure that this
doesn't happen
in the future end quote now whether this
was a one-off instance or part of a
larger problem of questionable behavior
that twitch alluded to in their email
we don't know but such an instantaneous
perma-ban
is pretty rare for twitch and if you
know anything about airsoft fatty the
fact that he didn't have
mods or moderate his chat isn't
surprising since 2014 airsoft fatty has
created content the only way he knows
how
by turning on the camera and being
himself from shooting airsoft guns
smoking copious amounts of weed driving
various off-road vehicles around his
property
creating culinary delights the likes of
which broke college kids wouldn't touch
to the aforementioned lightsaber fights
what you see is what you get with
airsoft fatty
and what people saw they loved anger is
not the way of the joke
we fixed it somehow now we'll feed again
both those clips have millions of views
and kickstarted a youtube career the
likes of which
now has him hanging out in la with
famous people
and it was youtuber idubbbz who helped
make airsoft fatty
even more popular back in july 2019
after hearing about airsoft fatty and
watching clips of him online
idubbbz decided to track him down and
see what this guy was all about
the ensuing documentary full force is a
crash course in internet culture
and racked up tens of millions of views
what is going full force
that is where and the way i define it
someone is treating it as if they're
about to die and they are putting
everything behind it
it's easy to see why people love him his
happy-go-lucky zest for life
coupled with his casual lo-fi approach
to twitch and youtube
make him eminently watchable now that
being said
if airsoft fatty did do any of the
things twitch said he might have done in
that email
well then the ban is probably justified
but the important thing to understand
here
is that something has changed with
twitch and the way they handle
bands we go again to i guess some goofy
doo
doofy dabba doo scrappy doo be trying to
take me out with dooby doo's
but i guess zoinks shoe let's go he's
got the weed and the joints let's go
so while airsoft fatty not having
moderators
isn't that surprising what is surprising
is that twitch handed down this band
just out of the blue
nobody saw this coming including airsoft
fatty and this permaban doesn't totally
make sense to me
sure he had been temporarily suspended
once before
but this doesn't meet the three strikes
in your out stance
that twitch typically takes instead of
saying
hey dude you need to get some moderators
to pull down vods like that
they just got rid of him entirely which
is kind of
unprecedented for twitch now you
might remember when twitch permanently
banned a little streamer by the name of
dr disrespect
back in june of 2020. the news was so
big
my goddamn grandparents were hitting me
up asking about who this disrespected
doctor was
dr disrespect has finally broken his
silence
in regards to his twitch ban but we
still don't know
exactly the reason he was banned in the
first place
doc getting banned wasn't just shocking
because it was doc
objectively one of the biggest streamers
on the planet or because
we to this day still don't know what he
did wrong
no it was also shocking because it was
capital p
permanent the dock ban marked a turning
point for twitch that had been
years in the making prior to and
including his band that broke the
internet for a better part of a month
getting booted from the platform was a
huge deal
it marked a last straw reaction on
twitch's part like pre-doc
if you were permanently banned from
twitch you seriously [ __ ] up
that type of banhammer was reserved for
names like ice poseidon
and what did he do well he doxed an
airline and then a fan called in a bomb
thread so
yeah but after doc things seem to change
you can almost smell it in the air the
golden era of twitch where rules were
meant to be broken was
starting to drift away i mean as soon as
amazon bought twitch back in 2014
it was only a matter of time before they
became more buttoned up and more
corporate
as they attracted bigger and bigger
sponsors
like the [ __ ] nfl is on twitch
and if you look at late 2020 up until
right now
there's been quite a few permanent bans
on twitch in the last couple of months
and if you want to talk about temporary
bands [ __ ] we'd literally be here all
day
to be honest temp bands have shown to be
pretty useless
and for certain streamers a three-day
vacation is actually pretty beneficial
just look at xqc oh come on
now is all of this recent ban activity a
reflection of twitch's corporate
overlord mission statement
i have no clue but what i do know is
that
something has changed and i don't know
if it's a good thing now one of the more
recent perma-bans happened in january
like last week streamer wes by the way
has let's call it a contentious
relationship with twitch
he's been handed multiple different
bands after tasteless jokes on different
streams
landed him predictably i must admit
in hot water with twitch now on january
30th west by the way was permanently
banned from twitch
after he took a bunch of different food
and condiments
put it all into one inflatable pool and
then went
swimming in it was it funny and absurdly
[ __ ] gross
100 did he deserve to have his career
ripped away from him because of it
i don't think so no but i do understand
why twitch did it
this is not the first time wes has done
some questionable [ __ ]
if this was the first time some poor
schmuck behind the scenes that twitch
had heard about this guy
maybe the outcome would have been
different now when it comes to airsoft
fatty
twitch cracked down on him in a way that
doesn't help anyone
instead of giving him a chance to learn
from his mistakes as he stated he was
trying to do
they stripped him of his ability to
stream at all but hey
their platform their rules twitch can do
whatever the hell it wants but the
problem that twitch has had for years at
this point
is that those rules are constantly in
flux or
are being enforced at random now in
their terms of service twitch does talk
about what you can
and can't do with music but the problem
is the way that these punishments are
handed out to content creators
is seemingly random and inconsistent i
don't
understand you at all streamers critical
of twitch's opaque enforcement
have long pointed out that certain
streamers
and they don't even have to be mega
famous have gotten away with breaking
certain sections of twitch's terms of
service
while other streamers have been punished
for the exact same thing
this was common with music for example
before the dmca apocalypse
royally [ __ ] everyone certain
streamers would get hit with bands
while others would be left untouched and
while of course there's been cries of
favoritism over the years
twitch's inability to consistently
police its platform in a way that's
fair most likely comes down to the fact
that it's
really [ __ ] hard to do and honestly
i don't envy the people tasked with
making it
fair and as for airsoft fatty give him a
chance to defend himself
and let's figure out if he actually
broke the rules or if this is just an
honest mistake
that dude is a content genius in his own
way
and it would be a shame to see the joy
he brings to so many people
disappear especially if he did nothing
wrong
he describes the air the the lightsaber
fights and like some of the other stuff
he does as a larping
and i want to do larping larping seems
so [ __ ] cool
you're right my character would have to
be like so close to who i
am that i would almost get confused as
to like
who i'm being right now you know what i
mean